sal has been practicing something called
tree meditation the tree is the epitome
of love i mean it's god's greatest gift
and what i try to do is i i try to blend
my molecules with the molecule of the
tree and what i do is when i meditate
now i'll hug a tree and i rest my
forehead against the tree and then and
you'll walk me into the forest and see
imagine his wife like is doing the
dishes she looks out the window
against the tree
but how do you take your walks i'm
telling you howard hug a tree and tell
me how it feels you are going to love it
i have a question sal when you hug the
tree
yeah do the birds in the tree [ __ ] on
your [ __ ] head while you're doing
this
no they don't here's uh sal struggling
with words we asked him to read the word
cantankerous and uh he had just a lovely
problem with it here you go howard then
took a call from the content did you
guys put this word in on purpose
cantankerous cantantankaris
yes i did
howard then took a call from the
cantantankaris lump
howard then took a call from the
cantantangaris
ken cantacruz
did you guys add an extra extra there's
like an extra three letters in this
thing howard then took a call from the
cantan tankerous lump you can't even
speak
cantankerous what's wrong with you
that's what i thought it was it said
cantantankaris i i'm telling you howard
but it says c-a-n-t-a-n cantankerous it
just looked odd uh when it was written
out it looked like cantan
tankaris i don't know you know what you
are you're illiterate
[Laughter]